welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with sad news
it's breaking from Baltimore right now
the loss of a powerful voice you just
saw him among congressional Democrats
Maryland congressman Elijah Cummings
chairman of the House Oversight
Committee died early this morning at a
hospital in Baltimore he was 68 years
old and had faced a series of health
issues Cummings committee is one of
three leading the House impeachment
inquiry before that he led efforts by
Democrats to get information from the
Trump administration and that made him a
target of the president's criticism
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning the country lost a leader
this morning that is really putting it
well Tony this is a huge loss for
lawmakers here on Capitol Hill he was
someone who was emulated by younger
members respected by Democrats and
Republicans alike Cummings died
overnight due to complications from long
standing health problems Elijah Cummings
dedicated most of his life to public
service an attorney and former state
lawmaker he was elected to the US
Congress in 1996 we are the greatest
country in the world we are the ones
that can can go anywhere in the world
and say people the Baltimore native and
son of sharecroppers quickly became one
of the most powerful orator --zz in the
Democratic Party it is so painful I
can't even begin to tell you when
Democrats won back the house in 2018
Cummings became chair of the powerful
House Oversight Committee which routes
out fraud and mismanagement in the
administration the child is sitting in
their own feces can't take a shower come
on man what's that about it's a job
reserved for those who won't back down
from a fight
when Cummings was hit with a barrage of
angry tweets he defended his city not
himself I want people to come to
Baltimore we are a great city we really
are
I do not have time for people who want
to trash our city Cummings was open
about his recent health problems and
grew increasingly reflective during his
final months a lot of people do not
understand where my passion comes from
it comes out of pain passion purpose and
a statement
Cummings wife Maya who was also the
chair of the Democratic Party in
Maryland said quote he worked until his
last breath because he believed our
democracy was the highest and the best
expression of our collective humanity
and that our nation's diversity was our
promise not our problem it's been an
honor to walk by his side on this
incredible journey
I loved him deeply and we'll miss him
dearly
you know you're gonna hear a lot of
comments like that about Elijah Cummings
Nancy you know all the players on
Capitol Hill how do you think his
absence will be felt there well you know
Cummings was one of just a handful of
lawmakers who Democrats would often turn
to to make their closing argument on a
particular issue he was uniquely
talented at making those kinds of cases
on the House floor very argumentative
yes but also very passionate in a way
that few others could emulate but he
also had a lot of respect from the other
side and and that was something that you
could feel when you were in hearings
when you were in the halls of Congress I
remember talking to him just a couple of
months ago as he was trying to figure
out what to say after the president
called him a racist and called his City
Baltimore rat-infested and he was really
struggling with it he said I don't want
to make it all about myself and I really
want to take the moral high ground here
so I'm I'm gonna be thinking about it
over the next couple of days
he was very frank with reporters and
that that's something I'm gonna miss and
something I'm sure a lot of people
around here are gonna miss I think so
too pain passion purpose Thank You Nancy
you know we still don't know exactly
what the medical condition was but he
just released a statement from the
hospital saying my doctors anticipate I
will be returning to Washington DC when
the house comes back into session this
was September 30 so he anticipated that
he would be coming back so it's a big
surprise to wake up to this news this
morning